R
CRIME SKYROCKETING 30%
YEAR-OVER-YEAR.
A CREW MEMBER FOR THE SHOW
"LAW & ORDER" WAS SHOT AND
KILLED IN BROOKLYN THIS MORNING
WHILE RESERVING A PARKING SPOT
FOR THE PRODUCTION.
INVESTIGATION IS ONGOING.
NO ARRESTS HAVE BEEN MADE.
HE WAS A REACTION FORMER FLORIDA
ATTORNEY GENERAL PAM BONDI ALONG
WITH FOX NEWS LEGAL ANALYST
GREGG JARRETT.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHY IT WAS A
QUESTION.
WE HAD THE VIDEO, WE HAD THE
AUDIO, I DON'T WANT ANY TROUBLE.
HE WAS ATTACKED, HE WAS PUSHED
DOWN AGAINST THE WALL AND FELL
DOWN AND GOT UP TO DEFEND
HIMSELF AND AT THAT POINT IT WAS
CALLED SELF-DEFENSE, ISN'T IT?
>> YEAH AND LEGALLY HE WAS A
VICTIM FROM DAY ONE.
HE WAS ALWAYS A VICTIM.
NOT ONLY THAT BUT THEY HELD HIM
INITIALLY ON HALF A MILLION
DOLLAR BOND.
HE SHOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN HELD
IN JAIL.
WHAT IF SOMETHING HAD HAPPENED
TO THAT VICTIM WHILE HE WAS HELD
IN JAIL?
HE FINALLY GOT RELEASED FROM
JAIL BY A JUDGE AND OTHER
CHARGES ARE DROPPED.
LEGALLY HE NEVER SHOULD HAVE
BEEN CHARGED.
THE CRIMINAL'S DAD AND HIS
GIRLFRIEND SHOULD BE CHARGED FOR
STABBING THE VICTIM IN THE CASE.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE AND IT IS A
CITY IN CHAOS THERE, THAT IS
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE A D.A. WHO
DOESN'T SUPPORT VICTIMS OF
CRIME, IT'S GOING TO GET WORSE
AND WORSE UNTIL HE GETS BETTER,
UNTIL WE ELECT THESE PEOPLE OUT
OF OFFICE.
>> Sean: WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON
GOFUNDME POLICIES HERE?
HE WAS ONLY CHARGED WITH A
CRIME, NOT FOUND GUILTY OF A
CRIME AND YET IN THIS CASE, THIS
GUY, WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE.
HE FIRED THE BULLETS INTO THIS
WOMAN'S HOUSE WITH YOUNG KIDS.
>> YEAH, IT'S COMPLETELY
BACKWARDS.
AND THE BODEGA WORKER, THIS IS
THE ONLY CASE I'VE SEEN RECENTLY
WHERE AN IDIOT PROSECUTOR
ACTUALLY FILES CHARGES BEFORE
CONDUCTING AN INVESTIGATION AND
THAT SHOULD'VE BEEN AN EASY ONE,
LOOK AT THE TAPE.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS THAT MAJOR
CITIES LIKE NEW YORK ARE RUN BY
LIBERAL DEMOCRATS AND
PROGRESSIVE D.A.s THAT HAVE
INSTITUTED THE SOCIAL JUSTICE
POLICIES THAT HAVE NOTHING NOTHO
WITH JUSTICE.
THEY ONLY INCENTIVIZE CRIME AND
CRIMINALS ARE TREATED LIKE
VICTIMS, AND INNOCENT VICTIMS
LIKE THE BODEGA WORKER ARE
CRIMINALS.
THE LEFTISTS WHO CONTROL THESE
MUNICIPALITIES DON'T BELIEVE IN
"LAW & ORDER."
-- A BAIL FOR MOST OFFENSES
CREATED A REVOLVING DOOR OF
CRIMINALITY AND THE REPEAT
PERPETRATORS LOVE IT WHEN THEY
ARE ARRESTED, BACK ON THE
STREETS BEFORE PAPERWORK IS
COMMITTED, THEY ARE COMMITTING
MORE CRIMES.
THE BLM AND DEFUND POLICE
MOVEMENTS SHATTERED EFFECTIVE
POLICING, I COMMEND THEM FOR
DOING THAT AND THEY FEAR
RETRIBUTION FOR SIMPLY DOING
THEIR JOBS.
HANDCUFFED BY SENSELESS POLICIES
AND POLITICIANS WHO RESIST
COMMON SENSE.
>> Sean: WILL THIS CHASE
PEOPLE OUT OF CITIES CUSTOMER
THERE WAS A STUDY THAT SHOWED
44% OF SAN FRANCISCO RESIDENTS
WANT OUT IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SAN FRANCISCO, PORTLAND,
NEW YORK, SADLY.
SO MANY OTHER PLACES AND WHEN
YOU HAVE STARBUCKS SAYING THAT
IT IS NOT SAFE TO HAVE THEIR
STORES OPEN IN MANY OF THESE
CITIES, THAT IS A HUGE PROBLEM.
IT'S NOT A RECIPE FOR CRIME
REDUCTION WHEN YOU HAVE D.A.s
SUPPORTING CRIMINALS OVER
VICTIMS.
WHEN YOU HAVE POLITICIANS NOT
BACKING UP OUR GREAT MEN AND
WOMEN IN BLUE.
WHEN CRIMINALS ARE MORE
EMBOLDENED THAN POLICE OFFICERS.
IT'S A PROBLEM AND IT'S GOT TO
CHANGE.
THAT IS WHY PEOPLE HAVE GOT T